este minero puede sentirse aliviado de
estar por fin al aire libre durante dos
semanas estuvo atrapado a cientos de
metros bajo tierra con sus otros 21
compañeros
una explosión arrojó escombros al pozo
del ascensor de la mina bloqueando por
completo la salida mientras el agua
subterránea empezaba a subir si no fuera
por los cientos de rescatistas que se
apresuraron al lugar y perforaron
agujeros para enviar comida agua y
medicinas él y sus compañeros podrían
haber muerto
los rescatistas revisaron a los mineros
para ver si tenían heridas y cubrieron
sus ojos para protegerse en general la
operación de rescate procedió más rápido
de lo esperado después de sacar a todos
los mineros encontramos continuaremos
con la búsqueda de los otros
desaparecidos
este gráfico muestra lo que han hecho
los rescatistas tras la explosión
localizaron a 11 de los 22 mineros que
trabajaban en el momento del incidente a
unos 580 metros de profundidad los
rescatistas hallaron a otro hombre en un
pozo 100 metros más abajo durante días
se comunicaron con ellos y continuaron
perforando mientras descendían para
buscarlo encontraron a otro minero
varado con el que no habían estado en
contacto en estas imágenes se ve que el
hombre ni siquiera puede ponerse en pie
primero nos encargamos del caso más
crítico este es el principio en el
rescate de accidentes mineros
entonces priorizamos los casos de
condiciones físicas y psicológicas más
delicados
los rescatistas tienen pocas esperanzas
para otros 10 mineros de los que no han
tenido noticias desde la explosión los
accidentes son comunes en las minas de
china porque las regulaciones de
seguridad no siempre se hacen cumplir
aún así el número total de muertes ha
disminuido en los últimos años a medida
que las autoridades aumentan la
supervisión